>>> HI, HBO, I'M PETER DINK.
>> AND I'M AMELIA CLARKE.
AND THIS IS YOUR FIRST LOOK
GAME OF THRONES SEASON SIX.
♪♪
>> SEASON SIX FINDS TYRION
THE SERVICE OF
DAENERYS TARGARYEN.
AND THAT MEANS I FINALLY GE
SOME SCREEN TIME WITH THOSE
SCENE STEALERS, THE DRAGONS.
[ BEEP ]
>> AND ACTION.
[ SCREECH ]
>> CITIZENS, DO NOT BE ALAR
CITIZENS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HE IS OUR FRIEND.
DROGON IS HERE TO PROTECT Y.
[ SCREECH ]
>> THE LOW CAP TECHNOLOGY AS
THE DIRECTOR TO SEE THE FIND
PRODUCT AS WE'RE SHOOTING I
REALTIME.
WHICH IS PRETTY PHENOMENAL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ SCREECH ]
♪♪
>> WELL, HE DIDN'T INHERIT
LOOKS, BUT HE CERTAINLY HASR
TEMPER.
>> GOOD JOB, PETER, WHY DONE
JUST DO THAT ONCE MORE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> I WAS JUST BEING INTENSE.
IS THAT --
>> YOU'RE LOOKING RIGHT AT .
>> OH, OKAY.5,fñ
I'LL CLOSE MY EYES.
>> SEASON SIX, THEY'VE REAL
PULLED OUT ALL THE STOPS.
I MEAN, SOME OF THESE EFFEC
THEIR DOING ARE JUST TRULY
INCREDIBLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
REALLY UNBELIEVABLE STUFF.
>> IT WOULD BE WISE TO TREA
LIGHTLY WITH ME, BOY.
WAR IS NOT A GAME.
>> OF THRONES.
>> OKAY, CUT!
RANDY?
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH, I THINK I JUST HEA
YOU SAY SOMETHING.
>> NO, I DIDN'T SAY ANYTHIN.
>> YOU DID, YOU SAID "OF
THRONES" AFTER HE SAID --
>> NO, CHECK THE PLAY BACK,
DIDN'T SAY A WORD.
♪♪
>> SEASON SIX HAS A LOT OF
SURPRISES IN STORE.
BIGGER, BETTER, BLOODIER.
>> HEY, ARE WE GONNA GET A
BATHROOM BREAK ANY TIME SOO?
I GOTTA BUST A --
>> IT TAKES LIKE A HALF HOU
GET YOU IN AND OUT OF THE S.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU THINK YOU CAN HOLD IR
A BIT?
>> YEAH, NO SWEAT.
>> COOL, GREAT.
>> THIS SEASON, I CAN'T SAY
MUCH WITHOUT GETTING IN TRO,
BUT LET'S JUST SAY THAT DAES
FINDS HERSELF RATHER CONFLI.
YOU KNOW, TORN BETWEEN TWO
DIFFERENT --
>> HOW ABOUT THERE?
>> GOOD.
>> YOU ONLY BRING PAIN TO T
KINGDOM, DROGON, YOU HAVE T.
[ SCREECH ]
>> OKAY.
HALT.
COME BACK.
A DRAGON WOULDN'T JUST OPEN
DOOR.
YOU JUST EXIT FRAME, OKAY?
>> YEAH.
I CAN'T HEAR YOU.
BUT I WAS GONNA SAY, A DRAG
SHOULDN'T GO THROUGH THE DO
I'M JUST GOING TO EXIT FRAM.
OKAY?
>> HERE WE ARE, WE'RE CURRE
SETTING UP FOR THE PIVOTAL
MOMENT WHERE DAENERYS LEADS
DRAGON INTO BATTLE FOR THE T
TIME.
>> OW!
OW!
>> LET'S BRING HIM DOWN.
>> IT'S PINCHING.
>> WHY DON'T WE BRING YOU D.
>> GIVE ME A MINUTE.
>> THANK YOU FOR WATCHING H
FIRST LOOK AT "GAME OF THRO"
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, .
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]